stop technically it's pascal because the  way they be running it pascal is the  five i'm putting them two or one i'm  gonna put my boat in for two cool two  okay two two for pascal baby  again four or do you want to go five i  thought that was your boy about four or  five how many people have started  centers worse than music murky four is  good four all right okay use some nerf  gets four  stop do you hungry eight [ __ ] three is  nice three he's gotta go three right  so far this yakima 2 is looking real  looking smart solid so far two more  spins to go stop  broke lopez  i like him yeah so we just need someone  that's better than the star  [Music]  you know was up there we was doing great  until that very last